and very pleased to say Sir Richard
Branson joins us on the program Richard
lovely to have you and uh thank you so
much for being with us just tell us a
little bit if you can about this docky
series
um Branson because I think it is fair to
say that over the course of your life
which has been an incredible life there
have been some controversies and this
does not shy away from looking at them
no it's a what's an old documentary it
was an independent film producer Chris
Smith
um uh I think he's got a fair balance
but let your viewers decide that on on
Sunday
um and uh and yeah I've had a full life
it's been you know I've been lucky
enough to be alive today
um you know I think there were you know
my my latest book um finding my
virginity I talk about the 67 different
ways I've come close to killing myself
um and this documentary I think some
sums up quite quite a few of them
um and and hopefully we'll have people
on on the edge of their seeds back in
those early days of of Virgin music I
mean did you ever conceive of living on
your own private island in the middle of
the British Virgin Islands you know uh
getting into space traversing the
Atlantic and the in the balloon I mean
did all of these things with all these
ideas bubbling at the back of your head
already or or has it been a bit of a
roller coaster for you as much as for
the rest of us
um it's been a complete roller coaster
um uh but you know I always dreamed
dreamed big I mean we started with you
know 200 pounds from a necklace that my
mum found in the street and handed into
the police station and nobody claimed it
so uh everything stemmed from from that
200 pounds
um and you know the island uh you know
we managed to to buy when I was in my
20s for all you know very very small sum
of money
um and then I dreamed one day being able
to live on it with uh with and it's it
was just some somewhere very very
special
um but um uh but uh um yeah but I I
pinched myself uh every day I wake up
because yeah the you know the idea of
building our own spaceship and you know
going to space in it and I was was
certainly something that when I was a
teenager I might have dreamed about but
never thought would I would the
realization would come come true can can
you can you talk to me about that moment
when you're floating and not quite zero
gravity but as close to his damn it
looking out of the window I mean I've
seen the footage and it just reminded me
again there that every time I have seen
anyone you know be it with your project
or or with others every single person
has this kind of look of awe of Wonder
and and just genuine Joy at the sight of
the earth below them was that it was
like that for you
yeah I mean it certainly one theory of
gravity because you know when the when
the rocket uh stops and there's this
incredible silence then you just
unbuckle and you literally just float
out of your seat and
um and then look back uh through these
giant windows at at the uh
um uh you know it it it's it's just
awe-inspiring and
um and to be doing it within a group of
other
um other young engineers and uh was
definitely it was definitely the you
know the most most incredible moment of
my life
um and then
uh so uh yeah so now now it's my job to
try to build a lot more spaceships so
more and more people who are watching
this program will will be in time able
to do the same thing and become
astronauts and go to space and
um and be able to what to wonder at this
extraordinary Earth that we live on yeah
I'm sorry I'm just looking at the
picture again it is absolutely
incredible if you find yourself with any
spare places do feel free to give me uh
to give me a show but but I suspect as a
as a businessman like yourself and it's
a story that we've we've heard from from
other uh prominent um uh Rich
individuals for every success like that
there must have been you know five six
seven failures I mean looking back over
the course of of your career what was
the biggest disappointment for you
well I think that the documentary that
goes out on Sunday you know
um oh actually I think it's it's either
that one or the or the following week
um obviously it has the the tears as
well as the joy so you know we we lost
one of the spaceships
um uh in in on it on a test run early in
early on and
um and that was a you know that was a
ghastly moment
um
um and you know there have been moments
like that throughout my life when
um you know we we've we've pushed we
pushed the limits and and and things
have not worked out and
um you know I mean in my balloon trips
uh
you know and and ended up I think in the
sea on about five different occasions
um and
um and uh so but by all by no means was
everything just smooth sailing
um from the age of 15 uh to the age of
72 we've had uh lots of ups and downs
but hopefully they've made us um
stronger for it are your ballooning days
over
I think my ballooning days are done
um you know we we got the record for the
first to cross the Atlantic and the
Pacific
um we we went almost around the world
and uh
um uh but we we've just been we were so
extraordinarily lucky to be able to come
home to our children and grandchildren
that I think maybe maybe I'll hang my
ballooning hat up from for the time
being anyway
um if I would just say to two people
ahead of this program that I was going
to be talking to a billionaire
businessman and entrepreneur with
investments in the space industry you
know if I hadn't if your name was not
the one that was mentioned Elon musk's
uh probably would be I just I just
wonder as someone who what who has
worked in the same areas as him who is
in the the same kind of category in
terms of cash you guys aren't all in
some kind of WhatsApp group of
billionaires kind of WhatsApp group
comparing notes I just wonder what you
might think of what's been going on at
Twitter of late
so we're friends
um and uh you know he was good enough to
you know come and see see me off for my
space flight and he's bought a ticket on
Virgin Galactic
um uh and you know we we communicate
when when he has his downs and his ups
and
um and uh and I sometimes write him a
note saying that you know as a as a
slightly older person I would advise
this or I would would advise that
um I mean obviously with Twitter he's
having a torrid time I would say and
um and uh and yeah I wish I wish him and
and and uh and the team there well
because you know Twitter is an important
part of uh the world and and it's one
he's just got to get right
um and and and but it's certainly not
look does it's not looking easy
you know it's not
um well we wish you well with with the
documentary Branson uh so Richard
Branson it's been a pleasure talking to
you thank you for getting up quite so
early for us as well appreciate it
thanks a lot cheers